my name is Barry Allen and an innocent
man I'm being framed for something that
I didn't do
he stood among our wolf sheep's clothing
this is the only way tell everyone
you're the flash if everyone knew my
secret we would never be able to stop
running this is John Constantine it's
getting a Britnie trenchcoat I'm gonna
clean traced warlock expert on the
occult
they tell you don't like horror movies
DC's legends of tomorrow all new
episodes return February 2018 on the CW
hey everybody there's a whole bunch of
new flash DC TV that we need to talk
about and there's a big schedule change
that a bunch of you have been asking me
about so I'll try to explain what's
going on when all the shows come back so
if you are finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway I'll name a new winner at the
end of this - so starting with the flash
we have the trial of the flash I don't
think that they're going to prolong it
for as long as it went on in the comics
because it was like this whole big thing
but courtroom drama is just not what the
flash is all about but the comic book
arc is all about Barry Allen proving
that somebody was manipulating the jury
behind the scenes I don't know they're
gonna take that tactic with the flash TV
show because the twist of the comic book
are a little ridiculous and it winds up
being abracadabra that's behind
everything and I don't know when he's
coming back to the flash TV show and on
top of that the comic book storyline was
all about him supposedly killing the
reverse-flash
so because the TV show version is all
about him supposedly killing the thinker
I'm just expecting there to be more
changes besides just the characters so
maybe one two episodes tops but they do
tend to go for the iconic comic book
cover so there's this one of him behind
bars in the flash costume there's this
one of him in the fetal position on his
prison bunk looking like he's crying
himself to sleep because all hope is
lost like they really want to make you
wonder whether or not he's still going
to be the flash spoiler alert Barry
Allen's gonna be the flash for a long
time so it'll be interesting to see what
twist they uncovered during the TV shows
version of the trial to prove that the
thinker was trying to frame Barry but it
might be one of those situations where
the investigation is ongoing and you
only spend a little bit of time in the
trial and then they just solved the
crime by the end of the season or in the
last couple of episodes because right
now it seems like the theme that they're
going with is that the thinker has
effectively won because he got the body
he wanted he's been reborn
so the thinker's supposed to have gotten
more powerful but I think the way they
visualize his powers will be relatively
similar
he'll just be walking around in broad
daylight not stuck in the wheelchair but
talking about Wally West now this is
where he comes back in because if Barry
is out of commission as they imp
in the trailer like how can he be the
flash on the street and Barry Allen
behind bars at the same time you totally
have a backup flash that's been fighting
starfish from outer space for the last
couple of weeks just waiting for the
opportunity to come back so while all
this is going on with Barry it
sounds like Wally will have an
opportunity to help out but I know we've
been talking about Wally going on one of
the other TV shows because Barry behind
bars isn't a long-term solution for
handling all your character problems
there's always way too many characters
on the flash for them all to get really
amazing storylines somebody's always
gonna have to ride the bench so of
course Constantine is coming to legends
of tomorrow for a two-episode arc and
they have no more firestorm meaning that
there's a couple slots left in their
roster so somebody has to replace them
they've confirmed that it's gonna be a
pre-existing character so everybody's
like what about Wally West
what about Constantine on a more
permanent basis I don't think it's gonna
be Constantine this season because Marc
Guggenheim who's also the executive
producer on Legends said that he was
only coming for a two-episode arc so if
Constantine comes on a more permanent
basis that it wouldn't be to a future
season but whereas previously i thought
that wally west would actually be a
really good option for legends of
tomorrow there's also a lot of people
that are wondering if it might actually
be killer frost because of a picture
posted to both of the actresses
instagrams recently in her bull killer
frost makeup on the way brighter with
Caity Lotz
so for all of you asking about this
killer frost rumor I actually think this
picture is just from the crossover
episode because for all four of those
episodes any time she wasn't wearing her
white canary outfit she was wearing
black so I think they took this picture
while they were filming Waverider stuff
because everybody was taking all kinds
of behind-the-scenes pictures just
because they were having so much fun so
that's just my initial take away from
this photo here but we won't find out
who's going on legends of tomorrow till
February when it comes back so
everybody's confused because they
recently made an announcement it's
Supergirl in legends of tomorrow are
gonna trade off that Monday night
timeslot for the rest of their seasons
so there'll be a couple episodes of
Supergirl Monday nights like their it
would normally be but then it'll go on
break in legends of tomorrow we'll take
that Monday night
time slot for a couple weeks then you go
back to Supergirl episodes back to
legends of tomorrow and they'll just
flip-flop for the rest of their seasons
so what's gonna happen is is all the
shows are coming back the week of
January 15th
that's a Monday night Supergirl episode
10 Legion of super-heroes will air then
so they're actually doing Legion of
super-heroes it's really cool I'll
totally do a video for it but what'll
happen is is they'll have Supergirl
episode 10 11 12 13 then on February
12th
instead of doing episode 14 of Supergirl
it'll be legends of tomorrow episode 10
and then they'll air a couple of Legends
episodes in that Monday night timeslot
maybe three or four they haven't said
how many then you go back to Supergirl
for a couple more episodes then back to
legends of tomorrow for the rest of
their season and so on and so forth so
it should go without saying that that is
totally crazy but the reason why they
had to do this flip-flopping schedule is
it because they fired the show runner
from Supergirl in the flash it was the
same person who was running both shows
in what's happened is is they have
better leadership at the flash TV show
so the people that are left to pick up
the pieces after the showrunner was
fired are just better able to handle the
story for that show in the back half of
the season so Greg Berlanti had to come
in and pick up the pieces and help them
finish both of their seasons so he's
sort of supervising the back half of the
season for the flash and Supergirl but
for whatever reason the writers on
Supergirl
need more help so they're behind
schedule so they need more time to get
the rest of their episodes for the
season all planned out
so they needed to put it on break but
legends of tomorrow is going just fine
so they're like okay well we have two
shows doubled up on Tuesday we'll just
put one of them in that Monday night
timeslot when Supergirl needs to go on
break so that's why they're putting
legends of tomorrow one Monday and
having a tradeoff episodes with
Supergirl for the rest of the year so
it's totally weird so I'll just remind
people about the schedule as we go along
because it does seem like there's some
cool stuff happening on both shows and
we do want to find out which character
is going to replace firestorm on legends
so I'm absolutely fascinated by that and
I know a lot of people are like what
about Roy what if Colton Haynes came
back for the rest of the season the
reason why I don't think it's him is
because I think he's only coming back
for one or two episodes of arrow
but hopefully that answers a little bit
about why the schedule is so weird when
everything comes back but generally
everything is coming back that week of
January 15th aro still on Thursday
nights the flash is still on Tuesday
nights and what they're doing now -
because the Black Lightning TV show is
starting on that Tuesday night it'll be
right after the flash so instead of
legends after flash now it's gonna be
Black Lightning for the rest of the
season I don't know how many Black
Lightning episodes there are but we'll
see how it is congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last video
Isaiah Owens please private message me
so I can get your contact details
I'll just announce a new winner when I
post new DC TV sorry there's no real
update about Young Justice right now but
I will post a video when there's news
about it but click here to learn all
about Bart Allen and various children
during the crossover episode and click
here to learn all about star wars
episode 9 which actually just got a
title thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight